[Música]
se você ou se você descobrir se você tem
uma capacidade de inovar mas o que você
acha que tem é que muita gente acredita
que são pessoas sensacionais entender
ou seja é percebi que diante da
realidade existem três comportamentos
geralmente a gente adota comportamento
acomodava a gente finge que não é com a
gente
o que me incomoda a gente o
comportamento de vista ou seja o leitão
eu acho que o comportamento do jogador
eu quero que seja diferente especial
diferente para criar um novo alternativa
à sociedade
essas crenças descobrir que o dr
então quando se fala de inovação se
associa muito com tecnologia geralmente
você pensa no jogador cães tecnologia
inovadora porque não sei nada de verdade
o inovador comportamento
salvador é quando começa tudo ou seja
começa por você perceber que você pode
ser mais inovador do que você é hoje que
seu primeiro ponto
inovar é antes de tudo o comportamento
em seguida o inovador ele percebe que
ela é capaz de transformar a realidade
não só acredita que você é capaz de
transformar a realidade e não vai provar
que você acha que as coisas no mundo
então você percebe que a realidade muda
assim um só sou eu quem tem que mandar é
nada
você sabe que eu vá esse é um ponto
muito importante porque tem muito mais a
ver com o comportamento não falei nada
de tecnologia não existe a primeira
pessoa no preto
o risco é importante você lembrar que a
gravação não corre risco
logo nesse grau seja olinda é uma sanção
ligado a alguém como eu isso porque se
existisse hoje
então isso é uma coisa muito
interessante não tem negócios em risco
então por que isso é importante porque
com isso você mesmo consegue qualidade o
que você está fazendo
dependente da área você trabalha ou seja
tal como o voluntariado
quero fazer algo inovador você consegue
avaliar se você está fazendo com que
cada um fazendo agora é possível sim não
ia fazer algo que fosse extremamente
complexo
lado democrático então é a busca pelo
sentido de simplificar ao máximo disse
justificar o máximo que a inovação este
grande e se a parte difícil da gravação
então eu trabalhei para chegar ao modelo
mais simples iniciantes e novatos
você só precisa de uma capacidade tão
grande que a gente tem que a gente
subestimou imaginar não tem fronteira
imaginária ambiental urbano não tem o
primeiro atua até onde você atua de
maneira então o primeiro passo é falar
para o povo falou que eu possa ser uma
realidade que eu posso eu sou fã do
comércio
primeiro fui muito difícil imaginar
antes de construir e depois que você
imagina a dificuldade é que é algo que
você fica advogando você não sabe onde
concentrar sua atenção